for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy so
previously we mentioned that
tetrahydrofolate could have a variety of
one Carbon group said it donates and
we're gonna kind of show how we can
interconvert between those different one
carbon groups in this video and in order
to kind of understand this fairly well
you should keep in mind this
specifically that this is the portion of
THF that we care about and this is
nitrogen number five this is nitrogen
number ten and the one carbon group that
is going to be donated is attached to th
F at one of these or both of these and
nitrogen's and so that's something we
have to keep in mind as we go through
this it'll help you keep track of the
names and it'll help you make sense of
things so let's start up here with th F
with nothing on it okay and so first
thing we'll do is we'll add a one carbon
group and that one carbon will come from
form 8 which is the conjugate base of
the smallest carboxylic acid formic acid
and we'll get n 10 formal th F here with
that formal group attached to n 10 hence
the name this step is catalyzed by n 10
formal th f synthetase and it's got
synthetase because this requires ATP ok
so now we have that one carbon group on
there we can interconvert it here we're
converting it if we go down here and
with if we have this cyclo hydrolysis
reaction
we'll get this here okay we're now the
the group is attached to both the n 5
and 10 and that is n 5 and 10
methanol THF so that can be donated as a
methanol group and that can be converted
into a form amino group here on + 5 by
adding an NH 4 plus an ammonium ion that
is catalyzed by cyclo deaminase named
for the reverse reaction which of course
going this way so that would give us a
form of you know group attached to the
end five so we could donate a form amino
group them if you know that N five and
ten matheno th F can be converted to n 5
formal th F which is also a formal group
donor via the cycle hide cyclo hydrolase
reaction and you'll notice that between
that will notice that we have now two
different formal group donors we've got
a and B between the two a is the better
donor B is more stable so the N five
formal THF this guy is more stable than
the end 10 formal THF so it's not as
good at donating it a is a better donor
of the formal group if we have n 5
formal THF we can turn that into n 5 and
10 methanol THF via the n 5 and 10
methanol THF synthetase reaction and
again it's called the synthetase because
it requires ATP ok now so now we've
already seen a bunch of different steps
right all these are reversible these
steps that we've shown here so we can
interconvert between all these and these
are all fairly oxidized the end 10
formal in this formal group this myth
phenyl group in this form amino group
they're all so in the most oxidized or
at least reduced 1 carbon groups on th F
ok so we can reduce this n 5 and 10
methanol th F 2 n 5 and 10 methylene th
F again it's named in 5 and 10 because
that's at at that one carbon group is
attached to both those nitrogens and we
can get that by reducing it
starting with NADPH going to nadp+ this
would be catalyzed by the end 5 and 10
methylene THF dehydrogenase step like
name for the reverse reaction because it
acts on the methylene THF but this is a
reversible reaction can go either way
and we get the n 5 and 10 methylene th
of an intermediate the oxidizer
intermediately reduced one carbon group
now that's not the only way we can get
the n5 n 10 methylene THF we
and also get it where that one carbon
group there that portion comes from
serine right up here we said that most
of the one carbon groups come from the
side chain of serine okay so we'll start
off with th F here start off with th F
and that th F has can take basically
this side chain of searing with that
there's that one carbon group there and
give n five and ten methylene th f via
the serine hydroxymethyl transferase
reaction and when that happens the th F
of course becomes the N five and ten
methylene th F and the serine becomes
glycine writes lost that one carbon in
its side chain and this reaction
requires PLP as a cofactor and we've
seen that before where have we seen it
before we've seen it in transamination
reactions trans amination reactions
catalyzed by amino transferases so that
gives us n five and ten methylene th F
and this this carbon here is the primary
source for one carbon units as far as th
F goes and this intermediately oxidized
are immediately reduced and five and ten
methylene th F can be reduced further to
n 5-methyl th F using an NADH giving an
nad Plus this was catalyzed by in five
and ten methylene th f reductase and
this reaction is actually pretty much
irreversible irreversible okay and this
of course is the least oxidized or most
reduced one carbon unit that can hang
out on th F okay but this seems like a
lot of details what's really the point
here what's the idea the main idea is
simply that once we've got the one
carbon unit on th F it can be
interconverted
between the oxidation states allowing
THF to donate over
idea of one-carbon groups that's
basically the main idea here okay also
one thing I want to know is that this n
5-methyl th F is not a particularly good
methyl group donor and it's not going to
donate methyl groups very much in fact I
feel like that was kind of redundant
anyway the point is that uh we're gonna
see why this thing is particularly
important in the next video on
s-adenosyl methionine I hope that video
is helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying